[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to the
opening ceremony of the second annual
twenty20 Cairns Cup
my name is Tony rich I'm the executive
director of the st. Louis chess club and
organizer of the tournament and I'm so
happy to be here with you today the
Cairns Cup is one of the strongest
tournaments in history featuring the
best female players in the world
we have reigning world champions we have
former world champions and they will
play each other in a format that's
called a round-robin round-robin
tournament sar1 in which every
competitor will face each other once and
at the end of the tournament the player
with the most points takes home the
$45,000 first place share of the hundred
and eighty thousand dollar prize fund
there are a couple of people that I'd
like to thank this evening who made all
of this possible first of all I'd like
to recognize Shannon Bailey and all of
her staff over here at the World Chess
Hall of Fame ahead of a round of
applause a beautiful place and it really
does take an army of people to put on
events like that's everything from the
event planners and the caterers and the
production crew and the marketing and PR
efforts and graphic design and then the
people that actually produced the show
you know just like to point out a couple
of folks in particular
fleischman-hillard is our PR firm
spectrum studios as well as fat chimp
I'm sorry excuse me silverback studios
are our production crews so a big round
of applause for all of them as well
please the vision of the Karen's Cup was
really to create a top level tournament
much like the Sinquefield Cup but
featuring the best female players in the
world really we noticed that there was a
real glut there weren't enough events
that spotlighted the top female players
in the world that provided opportunities
for the top American female players to
compete against as well so we're very
honored and excited to host the the
Karen's Cup this year I know most of you
are used to me at this point in the
evening introducing dr. Jeanne Singh
field however since this is her
tournament I will instead introduce to
you her husband the Chess Club founder
and the Godfather of chess as she would
say Rex Sinquefield
thank you Tony and ladies welcome to st.
Louis it's really a thrill to have you
here and I know for some of you it's the
first time and I was talking to somebody
who it's her first time here and already
she has gone to the top of the st. Louis
Arch so I think this is a gutsy group of
people so yeah you know we're thinking
about having a strong tournament for
women who though that cost sell so
Jeannie I am thrilled the Karen's cup
that's Jeannie's maiden name is now our
premier annual event for women and it
means we're spending more money on chess
but I'm delighted that there's a
tournament named after you because it's
very deserving and it will also
encourage girls and women around the
country and around the world to take up
the game so with that please welcome to
God mother of chess Jean Karen st.
Philip now this is a lot of fun you see
just all these guys up here right now
this is great this is so I was looking
at the different places where people are
from we have you from China we have two
of you ladies from India
we got three from Russia one from
Georgia one from Ukraine and two from
the US
nobody from st. Louis so now this is
gonna be a fun tournament we really are
very happy that you could come all these
way to come and see st. Louis and see
the chests capital of America so it's
what I'm hoping to do while you're here
is for you to just experience the how
much we enjoy chess how much this city
loves chess we want you to take it back
to wherever you're from and we tell
people they got to come to st. Louis for
chess so I guess I I I think someone
else is going to introduce everybody or
was I supposed to do that
hey Tony I'm always told
she won last year who do you think is
gonna win this year come on
anybody think nah just too polite okay
there we go we'll turn it back over Tony
thank you Jeannie
so the st. Louis s look like Jeannie
mentioned you know we have focused a lot
on tournaments at the club and it's
really an opportunity for us to
spotlight the very best players in the
world male or female two young students
what we found is that whenever kids have
role models to look up to superstars to
follow in their footsteps that they
stick with things like chess they become
smarter they become better educated they
become cultured members of our community
and we're very excited to be able to
provide that here in st. Louis we
started with the US Women's Championship
we added the u.s. girls junior
championship we've now had an
international tournament the Karen's Cup
and all of these tournaments are yet
another example of how st. Louis really
is becoming or has become the epicenter
for chess at least in the US and I'm
hoping that it's true in the world as
well so we actually are lucky to be
joined now by the executive director of
US chess which is the leader of American
chess here her name is Carol Meyer and
Carol is a great partner with the Chess
Club girl good evening everyone I want
to just share a few words about our
partnership with the st. Louis chess
campus and and with respect to the
women's program at u.s. chess last year
at this event we announced a $100,000
grant from the st. Louis chess club that
was going to extend our activities to
support girls and women in chess and I'm
pleased to say that many of those
projects that were funded there were 11
projects funded throughout the United
States are wrapping up this spring and
we hope to be able to report soon the
results the outcomes of those projects
but in addition we've used some of the
funds to support top girls and women
players with some additional training
support as they prepared for major
events
I want to as as always express my
gratitude to the team here in st. Louis
I'm joy and Tony and Shannon you know we
do an awful lot together not just in the
the women and girls arena but in several
other areas and there's such a joy to
work with no pun intended and just they
exhibit the utmost professionalism and
everything that that they do and it's
it's just a real honor to be partners
with them and of course none of its
possible without the generosity of dr.
Jeanne and Rex Sinquefield and their
vision to expand chess not just here in
st. Louis but really put it out front
and center across the United States and
make it part of the mainstream culture
and so Jeanne and Rex thank you for
everything you do to support chess in
the United States at this point I'd like
to introduce Jennifer Shahadah
who is the US chess director of women's
program who wants to say a few words
[Applause]
thanks so much Carol yes last year at
this event my dream event we also
announced a partnership between st.
Louis chess club and us chess to promote
women and girls programming and the
results were so successful we had
workshops and at-risk communities in
Philadelphia my City California as well
as chess workshops for moms who were
just sitting around between rounds with
nothing to do now they learn how to play
chess so that's just three of the many
programs that occurred but what I'm
really excited about is that today I can
announce that program is renewed for
2020 so big thank you to the st. Louis
chess club and to the sinc fields for
your generosity
[Applause]
and I mean last year was an incredible
event the 2019 Karen's Cup but I have to
tell you this is like my dream field
when Tony started messaging me the
players that were being confirmed I was
like okay very okay and then of course a
couple weeks ago we found out that we
would also have the world champion here
so it's a tremendous field and I'm
really grateful to all of you for coming
as I know to stay on the top of chest
for so many years requires sacrifices
both on the board and off the board and
I know that some of you took long short
journeys um left families at home so
it's really meaningful to me so many
years you've stayed at the top well okay
in Chris's case not so many years but I
can't wait for the games to begin as
Carol and Rex alluded to earlier you
guys are such great role models and what
I find is that when you have a
tournament like the Karen's Cup there's
so many fighting games I can't tell you
how many students I showed you're
dazzling combination to last year it
really motivates people and I can't wait
to see what sacrifices we see on the
board in 2020 thank you
Thank You Jennifer so we're gonna do a
little Q&A session I know that you guys
get tired of hearing me speak and you
probably would rather hear from the
players so I want to kick things off ask
maybe a couple of questions maybe a
general one for everybody and then we'll
open it up to the audience and members
of the press as well if you guys have
any questions so to start with I'd like
to ask a very general question how do
you all feel about the state of women's
chats around the world is it where it
should be has it improved
what are your your thoughts and
impressions who wants to take it first
or I can randomly pick Harika looks
pretty interested oh hold on I think
everyone I think from the time I started
chess in 2000 I can see so much has
improved in women says so many best
ornaments with very good price funds may
be comparatively two men it's it's still
little less but if you see the positive
side it improved a lot and I hope it'll
improve further and specially this
tournament will be a milestone because
this is one of the best prize fun
tournament in closed defense so I I see
the positive points in know in the
growth of women says thank you very much
Alexandra did you have some thoughts
also
okay Katarina I just want to tell that
of Karina we're happy to be here and as
a mother of four children yes for it
motivates me to continue playing chef
let's say this kind of tournaments so
I'm very happy to play here wonderful
thank you I have a targeted question for
Valentin I'm gonna put you on the hot
seat here you won the Karin Scout the
inaugural year 2019 you were one of the
highest rated players in the field you
came in strong you had a smooth event
throughout it seemed do you feel
pressure going into the 2020 Karan's cup
to defend your title I like this
atmosphere and I'm really happy that
it's more players the best players and
okay let's see what's happened well good
luck my next question is for you
charissa chris is the youngest
competitor and the Karen's Cup she has
won the US girls junior championship now
twice right and if she keeps on this
pace she has many records that she will
continue to break do you feel how do you
feel coming into the Karin's Cup as the
youngest competitor maybe with the least
experienced is it an advantage or a
disadvantage of course I'm like
incredibly honored to be here to be
invited and yeah this is like probably
my strongest event yet so feeling a
little nervous but mostly excited who do
you think will be the toughest
competition in this event there is there
anybody that you're really gonna be
gunning for not really I think
everyone's gonna be equally tough so
such a diplomatic answer creature Thank
You charissa when June I have a question
for you also so those of you that aren't
aware jus in June is the reigning
women's world champion in classical
chess she defended her title recently
against Alexander coriaci Kuna from
Russia you know and it was a an exciting
match to watch the chess was very fun do
you think that having just won the
Women's World Championship match brings
you into this event with
maybe an advantage do you think that by
do you think you have a some
psychological advantage or do you think
that you're in more form perhaps do you
think the players would be because
you've just won the Women's World
Championship but that's just my opinion
and I think everyone here is I'm looking
forward for exciting games here great
one more question for you you've played
in st. Louis now this will be your
second time you played one of the
classic tournaments right it's also it's
against men players what is your
impression of st. Louis and the Chess
Club in the Hall of Fame well I think I
like to be here thank you very much and
good luck I'm now I'll open it up to the
audience are there any questions in the
audience if you're representing media
please state your name and what your
media outlet is also Jeanne has a
question last year I thought that the
games were much more exciting than the
Sinquefield cup games so how come the
women play more aggressively and have
more exciting games
and I think government always wants the
people surrounded by to be happy and
enjoying that makes them play the most
interesting games this question is
actually for Alexander Rena Alexandra
and Katerina excuse me
you both have played here I guess last
in 2011 the Chess Club had an event
called Kings versus Queens and it was
men versus women how do you think that
that chess has changed especially the
events that you're competing in since
2011 well I just remember that I was I
like to load this the tournament and
well of course I waited the opportunity
to to come here again and finally
finally I'm here so but I remember my
tournament it was really really tough
when I played Hikaru well what shall
actually he he was out of the board you
know he was everywhere but not just
sitting in front of me and he won easily
well let's try to play tournament we'll
see how it will go
thank you good luck Alexandre yes indeed
the first time I visited st. Louis was
in 2011 and I fell in love with the
place with the club who's the atmosphere
I liked it so much that we came back
with my husband just to have a look at
the sink a full cup 1 August and I was
very very happy to find out last year
about the scarran's Cup tournament which
i think is phenomenal for women's chess
and yeah definitely since I started my
chest career it's been a while and it's
changed
it's changed quite a bit I must say well
the number of women's tournaments the
prize fund of women's tournament and
that's amazing and I think that's well
that's very important to have such
tournaments with such prize fund because
first of all it motivates the girls who
play chess and second it motivates chess
enthusiasts to create more such
tournaments and it's like a pyramid so
it's very important and thank you very
much for doing this for promoting
women's chess great thank you so much
are there any other questions
Jennifer shadi for girls who are
watching this or really anyone who's
watching this who's trying to get better
at chess do you have any advice on how
you watch the Karen's Cup and watch your
games in order to also improve at the
game who hasn't answered a question yet
maybe Maria could answer this oh you had
a specific this time we decided to come
and to play myself it's a kind of
tournament about all the chess players
are very strong and it's really hard to
predict who will become the winner and
therefore I think it will be very
interesting for the spectators and I
hope boom we will see many nice and
exciting games Thanks great thank you
anything else by the way I definitely
should mention to you I'm sorry I didn't
say this we've got the best commentary
team any sport hands down baseball
baseball doesn't even touch us we're
lucky that we're actually joined by so
many great commentators when I call your
name please stand and they will do a
round of applause for all of the
commentators I'll start off with our
commentary team that will be operating
out of kingside diner that's for our
live audience and that commentaries also
streamed live on Twitch comm we have
women's Grandmaster tattoo of Abraham
yen and Grandmaster Christian Corolla
for our russian-speaking audience in
Studio B I was really gonna try to do
this just with a little bit of Russian
but I decided it would not embarrass
myself
our Russian commentators in Studio B
really do an amazing job we have
international master Elmira Script
chenko and women's Grand Master ah
nostalgic Karlovic and in studio a
broadcasting from the st. Louis chess
club as they always do we have women's
grandmaster two-time US Women's Champion
Jennifer Shah hottie grandmaster yasser
sarah juan and joining us at the
smartboard this time around will be
grandmaster alejandro Ramirez you know
it's funny this is gonna sound bad I
didn't know how hard it was to be a
commentator until I tried to do
something on camera where you play chess
or analyze chess while you're talking I
did a stream on Twitch comm where I
played the people and literally I'm just
dropping pieces left and right and I'm
still trying to carry on a conversation
and I can't do either thing well so I'm
really amazed by what you guys can do
you really make the show a lot of fun
and you really break things down for
poachers like me okay so I guess our
next step really would be to introduce
to you a special guest that we have here
Michael Crowe Tokarski is a longtime
friend of the st. Louis chess club you
know he's helped us with planning events
he's spent a long time for - garry
kasparov - so when you see Gary come to
town you often see Michael as well
Michael's a feat a vice-president and in
that role he's joining us in an official
capacity to represent fee day and say a
few words so Michael
so you know I got used already to some
ceremonial role to say a couple of words
and not to be to say big speeches and I
just want to say that st. Louis and
actually it's great state of Missouri
its capital of American sport right now
because Stanley Cup champions are here
Super Bowl champions are here actually
Kansas City and capital of American
chess is here and we have reigning world
champion here and former world champions
as well and reigning a blitz world
champion here as well right so on behalf
for the presidential board I would like
to congratulate first of all sinful who
were able to bring this amazing event
back to st. Louis and as I mentioned
last year they even they could do
anything including good weather so they
actually array arranged everything with
even two groundhogs Sunday that say
that's spring around the corner and
certainly I wish all participants great
games great competition and good luck to
you thank you thank you Michael so the
players are always very patient they
wait calmly they smile they're very
poised
but really they come to the opening
ceremonies because they care about the
drawing of lots this is the point in the
night where we actually determine the
order in which the players will face
each other and what color they'll play
each other against so to help me with
the drawing of lots I will be joined up
here by chief arbiter of the event
international arbiter Anastasia Sorokina
Anastasia and I also have deputy arbiter
international arbiter Chris Byrd who
will actually be officiating and writing
down the pair
these will be the official numbers that
we use to pair all the players so
players just a reminder as you come up
please come behind the table here you
will select a wonderful hat and scarf
just kind of point to it anastagia will
take it off there's a pairing number
that's actually under the Hat here and
so that's how we will determine the the
order so to start things I would like to
begin with the defending champion of the
29th from the 2019 Karen's Cup
Grandmaster Valentina Goo Nina she chose
a white hat do you think it'll be a
white number ah Valentina draws pairing
number 7 thank you very much joining us
next
the reigning classical women's world
champion hailing from China
drew injury
[Applause]
and when June has Perry number 10 thank
you joining us next from India the
reigning woman's world rapid champion
Pompey Koneru Hampi has chosen parry
number 2
next up hailing from Ukraine we have
Grandmaster Maria Musa Chuck Maria
thinks pensively and pairing number 1
next up the reigning woman's blitz
champion hailing from Russia we have
Katarina Llano Katarina has chosen parry
number 3
next up from India we have grandmaster
Harika drona volley and Harika choses
pairing number eight next up from a
country that's known for having
powerhouse email chess players reigning
from the country of Georgia
Nonna's agony Z and not I actually
competed last year too
and she chose pairing number four next
up from Russia former women's world
champion grandmaster alexandra costume
yuck
and alexandra has pairing number five by
the way for the noun chess players in
the audience if you get pairing numbers
one through five this is an advantage in
a tournament like this it means you end
up having the white pieces for five out
of the nine games in black out of only
four and so having whites a slight
advantage as you can see right there
joining us next from the United States
hailing from Brooklyn we have
grandmaster irina crush irina chosen
pairing number six and there's a line
under it I'm sure it's a six thank you
very much and then just to make sure
that things are fair I'm gonna ask
women's Grandmaster charissa up to come
join us and draw her perry number and
Carissa does indeed have earring number
nine so now that we have all of the
pairing numbers down I'm happy to
announce to you what the first round
pairings will be in just a reminder you
can follow all the action live at us
chess champs comm will have all of the
commentary streaming there as well as
YouTube and twitch so in round one we
will have grandmaster maryam Uzi truck
versus reigning world champion
Grandmaster Jew in June we have hum
Pekin arrow versus charissa yep Katarina
Llano will play her eco Drona volley
Nana's agony Z will play Valentina Goo
Nina and will wrap up with Alexandra
Costra
playing against Irina crush so it'll be
a very exciting first round I know every
round of this tournament it's going to
be hard fought and so much fun I'm gonna
make sure I don't miss anything that's
on my list here yes so if this is your
first time in st. Louis make sure that
you check out all of the exhibits here
at the world chess Hall of Fame this is
really an amazing place if you haven't
stopped by this is the time to spend
some time here and really kind of see
the full exhibits talk to the curators
talk to the the docents that are here
they'll be happy to answer any questions
that you have don't forget to stop by
King side diner and check out the
commentary with Christian and Tata and
make sure that you tune in every day
live at 1:00 p.m.
thanks for joining us and we'll see you
all tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
you